all right I love this story and I think
this is gonna be writing Alonso's
wheelhouse comic Alliance put together a
list of the superhero movies a timeline
of the superhero movies for the next six
years that's going to get us to 2020 and
there are a boatload of superhero movies
coming out let's take a look okay so in
2014 we actually only have one more
we've only got a couple months of the
year left big hero 6 which I'm told
Alonso my people tell me you saw already
dude even though it's not out yet yes is
there anything you want to hint us about
it I liked it
you like Jordi better view at the rap
okay there you go so yeah 2015 we're
gonna get the next Avengers then ant-man
Fantastic Four and I interesting Lee
Fantastic Four the comic book they just
announced that the comic book is dying
or dead or they're killing it and like a
month or something
Deadpool Batman Superman next Captain
America another x-men etc etc and we got
Wonder Woman in 2017 another Wolverine
they've done like 87 of those sinister
six which I think is going to be an
offshoot of spider-man if I'm not
mistaken Fantastic Four two in 2017 then
we'll jump we'll just skip ad' then we
got there justice I mean this trip goes
on and on you guys can all look at this
yourselves Venom's getting his own
that's another spider-man offshoot Lego
Batman I guess from the lego movies he
people like him right then I like this
one Marvel in May of 2018 is just doing
unknown movie and then they're following
it up in July with another unknown movie
and then another one in July another
unknown but is at least gonna be in the
x-men universe so obviously yeah you got
to own that weekend early oh just put
just I'm putting a peg get on the
calendar and it's gonna be a thing yeah
everybody else stay away so as as a
movie guy when you see this now III
generally love all these movies a couple
of them you know I'll see and I don't
really like the Fantastic Four that
they're now rebooting I didn't like the
original two but pretty much I like all
these I have liked more of these movies
than I have not yet for the most part
I'm you know I grew up reading comic
books I'm not averse to okoma group
movie superheros but when you see it all
list it out like that yeah I have to
admit a part of me as a film critic
things
you know it's like because nobody ever
sat down and said like here is every
romantic comedy you're going to see for
the next five years you know that would
that nobody plans that kind of thing
but boy just the idea of all of those
sequels and read threads and I mean like
they're rebooting Green Lantern in 2020
I guess that'll be a long enough time
for the stench of the Ryan Reynolds one
to go away which I didn't hate um yeah
so you know yeah and look they're making
money I there's a real that was a really
interesting piece the only times
recently about how the reason that the
potato famine happened in Ireland was
because they were a one crop economy and
when that one crop fails you are [ __ ]
yeah and Hollywood has become a one crop
economy and that's it that's the crop
and they're making movies and now and
there's movies are making money now but
when they stop making money then what
okay so I'm totally glad you brought
that up because it seems to me that this
is all we can create anymore in America
we lost all our manufacturing jobs right
we don't have much we're not creating
much but one thing we can do and that we
still do basically well is the
blockbuster movie so the studio's sort
of have to do this right they can sell
it in China yeah that's selling in China
transformers for I did my review on it I
saw your review on it can we make sure
that Michael Bay does not how do we do
this how do we set it up again his
movies keep making money so we our
trailer disaster where do you where do
you fall on these super movies you dig I
love ya I'm with you guys I love
superhero movies I'm excited that DC is
getting some more love these days and
yeah I think I mean I tend to prefer
when they are a little more serious in
nature like The Dark Knight Syria the
trilogy is still like one of my favorite
things that's ever been made but yeah
you know it is weird seeing them all
sort of laid out like that but I think
that like the fret the big franchise
nature you know of Hollywood you know
investing so much into the you know sort
of tried-and-true also kind of paves the
way for more sort of unique films I feel
like I mean this was a really good year
for film we had gone girl which was
awesome boyhood which we were talking
about before and then Birdman which I
just thought which was amazing yeah and
even within the framework of these
things I mean guardians of the galaxy
who would have
that was gonna be like a comic book that
not even comic book nerds are like big
which one was that one you know so
they're there at least thinking like
okay we have this brand we have a fairly
built-in audience we can maybe play with
this a little bit and so if they
continue to do that then that's exciting
and that that has possibilities you know
and and I think that I would be maybe a
little more excited about the DC stuff
if Zack Snyder weren't directing so many
of them but that's neither here nor
there but no I mean it's here or there
but you know these are these aren't
characters that have worked and that for
a lot of people have a lot of meaning
and and could be turn into something
really fun but I just worry that there's
so much of it in such a concentrated
period of time that they're daringness
to get sick of it base yeah is there to
just play devil's advocate on that is
there possibly because of the way the
studios are doing this and the way that
they're laying this out in advance that
they're able to make the worlds much
bigger I mean that seems to be what
they're doing they're you know they give
you a little plot point so in the
spider-man 2 for example you already had
the plot of that the sinister six we're
already coming so there is some
foresight which is nice as opposed to
just throwing out one movie and then
trying to figure out a sequel that
really just you know yeah I mean I think
you know I bet if Marvel had its
druthers they would own all of their
characters but for a long time they were
licensing him out here and there and so
you had like a daredevil movie that had
nothing to do with the spider-man movie
they're done they do the next one we did
with the Fantastic Four movie so now
they're sort of approached that this is
really going back to the 60s and the
Marvel Universe when it was originally
created and the idea that there would be
this interlocking continuity of all this
stuff even DC kind of followed Marvel's
you know lead on that one
and so yeah they want to expand out the
the Cinematic Universe and have the
Avengers meet the guardians of the
galaxy and have Doctor Strange meet
spider-man whatever sure you know I
again I mean there's certainly potential
there but there's also the potential to
just if we have to see another goddamn
origin story that we're all gonna shoot
ourselves in the face right like I get
it he was bit by a radioactive spider
you gotta show me another
what does it say about us that comic
books are dying while this stuff is
blowing up that's just like you know
things are changing what are you gonna
do paper there on paper like is that but
you know you get them on iPad now I'm
sure I think it's just that like people
crave myth and it doesn't matter the
medium it's just that like for today the
way you know stories you know the the
amazing way and which stories are now
able to be told in cinema I think has
sort of displaced you know our attention
you know our necessity for comics which
i think is like sad but definitely have
been dying for 40 years you know I mean
you look at the numbers they were
getting in the 60s even like our romance
comic which is back when they were
actually gearing comic books to you know
female readers you know giant numbers
and then over time you know yeah the the
movies get bigger and you had your
Superman movie in your Batman stuff
whatever but the numbers are constantly
shrinking you know you'll occasionally
get some cult item like you know Frank
Miller doing the Dark Knight or Watchmen
or something and then you know there was
that that awful period the 90s where
they became beanie babies and everybody
was buying up foil emboss number one
issue that then became useless because
everybody owned them and they were worth
nothing yeah so I mean it's constantly
been in the numbers have always been in
decline but they I think you know it
would be nice if these movies would
drive some traffic to the comic book
store I don't know that necessarily it's
happening but at least it's keeping the
publishers alive the the money they're
making off of these movies right alright
well thank you guys for taking a little
time from your busy superhero movie
schedule to tune in with us